رغم كونها صغيره وضيقه للغايه طولها يبلغ
سته امتار ونصف وزنها اكثر من عشره الاف
كيلو جرام يمكنها حمل طاقم مكون من خمسه
اشخاص وبالتالي فهم لديهم مساحه محدوده
للتنقل ويتعين عليهم الجلوس على الارض
وجهز باحدث انظمه الاضاءه والملاحه بجانب
معدات التصوير والفيديو بتقنيه
وثم ده في الداخل وفي الخارج وتستخدم
لاغراض البحث خاصه البحث في حطام السفينه
الشهيره تيتانيك الواقع على عمق 3800 متر
تحت سطح المحيط الاطلسي ولهذا السبب كانت
عمليات البحث الصعبه لتقريب الصوره مساحه
منطقه البحث هي ضعف مساحه ولايه
الامريكيه اكثر من
14,000 كيلومتر مربع
وحاولت فرقه الانقاذ تسهيل مهمه البحث
المعقده تم ارسال مركبات التي تعمل تحت
الماء عن بعد ومنها مركبات اوديسيوس
هي يمكنها العمل على العمق الكبير للغواصه
وحطام تايتنك نحو سته الاف متر مشاهدينا
البحريه الامريكيه استخدمت هذا النوع من
المركبات بالفعل العام الماضي لتحديد
واستيعاده الطائره المقاتله المحطمه على
عمق
3780 مترا في بحر الصين الجنوبي ايضا تم
نشر طائرات والقوارب فوقها وتحت سطح البحر
اسقطت هذه الطائرات اسقطت عوامات صوتيا هي
صغيره نسبيا تقوم بمهمتين وهي الاولى ان
الكشف النشط عبر السونار لمكان السفن اما
الثانيه كشف غير نشط للاستماع وتحديد
الاصوات الخاصه بالاله تحت السطح
هيكلها قوي على شكل اسطوانه او كره بمجرد
تغير هذا الشكل بسبب الضغط ضغط المياه
الهائل سينفجر كما شاهدنا الان كل شيء ان
سيصبح مثل علبه الصفيح بوصف احد المهندسين
الذين اشرفوا على انشائها حدث الانبجار
ابي بالفعل نهايه ماساويه كادت تحدث ايضا
في حادثه مشابهه قبل 23 عاما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات